you know 20 years worth believing in
myself and now I'm sitting here getting
interviewed by Mike Tyson no doubt I'll
get you it's my first podcast ever
really yeah first time ever be not like
that won't be a mask
we're honoured row - hi I'm honor to be
here brother that's also know and you're
doing it with a tarantula on your head
when putting in it I do not know thank
you oh thank you got this bro this is
gonna go viral the podcast is gonna be
hitting 20 million views and they see
Mike Tyson but a fast rental on his
forehead my forehead bro trust me we're
gonna find him first
I feel them I mean I want to get this on
that I can't do this [ __ ] [ __ ] no way
bro he's chillin he's a cool arachnid
that's pretty dope we're scared of
spiders I have a rectifier one of those
guys you know [ __ ] I shut my phone off -
I'm scared the definite thing he's
amazing where does this guy come from
oh I think these guys come from South
America so cars taken they have Chilean
rose hair some chili oh sure a smoothie
species of spider that's kind of calm
okay I have some tarantulas that's like
reals
you know sporadic that move a lot we'll
address it with a real chill interesting
about the muses the skeleton like
tarantulas on a Chilean rose here he's
cool bro you should do it I mean it's an
amazing animal it food has a podcast
what a tarantula knife for head
yeah you should have Tigers back in the
day bro you had peppers are you yeah
well you was a bad man you are after the
baddest man on planet
you can't let this little punk-ass
eight-legged spider that weighs a
quarter of a pound
quarter pound spider how long am I
supposed to hold it 10 seconds you're
good
some [ __ ] amazing I gotta go talk
about this amazing bro
[Music]